GQ magazine more than 50 years been the  Bible at mens style and the home of  award-winning journalism now GQ leads  the way once more the first magazine  available on the iPad every page every  story  every photograph in all its riches  everything you love about GQ now  available two ways clean simple elegant  easy to use at the table of contents you  always know exactly where you are read  GQ and vertical portrait mode and  experience the latest issue an iPad  optimized for men read articles these  slideshows watch videos  or go horizontal can you get the entire  print issue in digital format best of  all you can keep your GP with you all  the time like forever go to the GQ  library you can pick up back issues of  GQ and add them to your app and when a  new issue comes out you can get it right  here it's your very own complete and  ever-expanding library for GQ it's every  page everywhere you go whenever you want  look sharp whip-smart get GQ on the  advent  you